incredible fight an absolutely amazing
fight which
in
in the course of trilogies it's got to
be way up there you'd have to say like
muhammad ali versus joe frazier their
fights right from 1971 to 75 was
absolutely incredible and fantastic
but for
two men to fight three times for the
world heavyweight championship of the
world
and everybody was had their
apprehensions about how this fight was
going to pan out because saisa fury was
an incredible victor in their last fight
for what these guys put on the line
was just
seriously for the analogues of history
it was absolutely fantastic both men
should be commended for how they
performed we had
five knockdowns right throughout the
fight
um tyson thai security going down twice
deontay wilder going down three times
and it was i'm i'm still shocked about
i'm still i haven't slept since watching
the fight this morning
yeah you're still buzzing from it i can
tell and and you're right there were
question marks weren't there about
fury's own preparation he'd have covered
amongst other issues yes but you have to
look at somebody like tyson fury who is
one million percent a boxer different to
someone like a deontay wilder who john
wilder's story is absolutely amazing um
he spent like three years as an amateur
boxer ended up qualifying to go to the
olympics came back with a bronze medal
tyson pure was born
when he came out with his mother's room
he must probably have box
because
it's in his lineage it's in his dna and
you could see that yesterday like people
were thinking that the fact that thai
security came in very heavy just under
um just under 20 stone thinking like how
is he going to to to be able to move and
navigate himself
carrying that weight deonte wilder
actually bulked up from the last time
that they fought he put only a stone and
a half it made no difference when tyson
truly says that he is a fighting man
that is exactly what he is and more so
than that is the respect that he shows
to previous past champions um tyson fury
is absolutely amazing we've seen
everything that he's gone through with
the mental health with um um the the
depression that he's gone through with
him not wanting to box him stepping away
from from boxing then becoming obese
losing ten stoning weight
i'm sure that's about your weight right
now right
right
you're very kind you're very kind um i
mean you talk about respect um wilder
wasn't quite as respectful was he
my friend
um
i'm i'm
i get why he wasn't
but
being like
looking at someone like tyson fury
there was no more excuses they they had
every excuse underneath the book um
uh the last time out saying like oh my
what was spiked um there was allegations
of of the glove tampering and all this
nonsense
maybe it's difficult for someone in his
position to just take it to say like i
was beaten by the better man
and it was sad because it put kind of
dampness on such
a fantastic fight
boxing is the sweet science
but unfortunately it became
the bitter fiction yesterday with
deontay wilder coming out or in earlier
the moon with jonte why they're coming
out with the comments they did after the
fight but the class of christian fury
when tyson crew was saying like you know
what uh i hope that the lord softens
your heart
you know everything learning it's about
progression so
hopefully
you know deontay wilder in
in in maybe in the near future we'll see
like it was wrong that was an error um
hold his hands up he's being fair and
square there's no excuses and he was
just in with the better man who who
faced adversity in the fight as well and
sucked it up bit down his gumshot and
came back and was vandal
yeah and what next for tyson do you
think a fight with anthony joshua no we
are we not forgetting two weeks ago andy
joshua just lost auntie justin even
though auntie joshua financially will be
a viable fight because people still will
be interested in it but we have to be
real the thing that those two men
deontay wilder
and tyson crew showed yesterday
in their fight was that they could bite
down on their gumshoe when everything's
not going according to plan
bite down on your dumb shoulder and and
show that you got that grip
unfortunately with anthony joshua this
is not disrespectful i love the guy but
he didn't show that against a smaller
man in uc two weeks ago
so
right now
this is properly um
we're liking a marvel comic because
everybody's looking for the phones right
now and tai chi crew holds a portion of
infinity stones and alexander ustic owns
the other portion so those two should
get it on but i must stress
dylan white has been number one
challenger for the wbc crown which is
held by tyson three for the longest time
and mauricio solomon who is the
who is the president of the wbc has said
like so you've got 30 days to decide who
you're going to fight where it's going
to be usyk or
dylan white dylan white's waiting a long
time that'd be a fantastic thing to have
dylan white and tyson fury at wembley it
will be
bring it on and uh spencer just show me
that mug again because i think there's a
face on there i recognize okay okay oh
there you go can you see that there he
is
a man
in there because i think you're still
buzzing from the fight aren't you
my friend i don't think you understand
like i
boxing is on a high
the fact that because of what was
demonstrated yesterday
um in in the fight or it's going to
bring
more youngsters to take youngsters off
the streets um
they will have things to do because
everybody's buzzing about it like i said
i haven't slept early this morning i'm
getting phone calls from former
professional fighters cliffstone
mitchell um uh
the guys from certain podcasts and
everything else undefeated podcast and
uh the fights right podcast everybody's
speaking about boxing because
what we saw
with tyson fury and deontay wilder there
was no loser in that fight
at all there was no loser great fight
it's a great fight it's great fights it
was like wow because
you know one hand cannot clap without
the other and they both needed each
other to clap and they clapped so loudly
it was absolutely beautiful to see